hello congratulations on the movie hey
thank you I am endlessly fascinated by
the storytelling format that obviously
has a very unique production process so
before you hit the set of this film what
were some of your biggest burning
questions in terms of what it would take
to actually make a movie that took place
entirely on a screen
yeah I was like okay where am I supposed
to look and what just happened and
what's going to happen after this and
oh where's the light and oh don't worry
about the light oh you want me oh it's
supposed to look bad because it's grainy
and it's a it's you know it's not a real
screen it's actually a a device so we
need to to have each device should have
its own look so I think
um I had a lot of questions from the
beginning to the end and
but then there were moments when I
thought don't don't ask just do what you
would normally do and clearly they're
going to catch it because there's like 9
000 cameras in the room
um and that was pretty freeing so
can you give us an example of a specific
time when an answer to one of those
questions was most shocking where the
process was like totally not like what
you had imagined
oh so we there is a scene where I'm
driving a car I have the phone in my
hand which wasn't a cradle but it didn't
really work for the shot so I had to
hold it
and then storm was in the back seat
reading her off camera lines I could see
myself and I was
oh and we were losing the light outside
so that was like I really felt like I
felt like a champ because I pulled it
off and we were in a car and you know
like when you're in a car shooting
you're even though the streets are
blocked up you're still in a car and now
you've got like other lives in the car
so I was like I can't this I've got to
make this work so the pressure was on
but we got through it as though
delivering a good performance isn't hard
enough already a million other things to
worry about right there
um you brought up storms so I'll go
there next I think she is one of the
best of the best in her generation and I
can't wait to see even more from her
going forward so what's something that
you really appreciated about her as a
scene partner or maybe just admired
about her own crap that you're excited
for more of her collaborators in the
future to get to experience I think
she's a pro number one she knows what
she's doing there's no like wait what
and she really commits she really
commits to the moment she commits to the
material
um she's got this
beautiful
gracefulness but then there's also like
that young woman in there that's still
excited about what she's doing and that
she's a part of something that's so
important and so big right like I
remember being her age and and and
working with John Singleton and
not really understanding the magnitude
of what we were doing it was just like
oh my God I got a job you know and she's
got this maturity and this Grace but
she's still very
this innocence and I think kudos to her
mom because to get that balance you know
Mom is is in there you know guiding the
ship and and pouring all the Nuggets
into her that she needs to become the
woman that she is today I love to hear
it she's something else you're wonderful
in this and it is a miracle that movies
like this could be made so seriously
huge congratulations I can't get over it
it's true I felt the same way thank you